[Music]
how do you choose your rules
I want to find a character that's
difficult to on the surface understand
were they born or were they made
such a pleasure to meet you you are so
sweet we're so happy to have you thank
you for doing this it's so generous well
I want you to tell a story right don't I
if you're taller you look taller on
television but we're basically the same
size basically the same
feels like things just settle down and
now y'all are making a movie it's a very
complex and human story I think it's
hard to trust then you're going to
represent Gracie's as she was I'm gonna
try
[Music]
when you first met
we came to the pet store looking for a
job it was summer after sixth grade
seven
what do you want to play me when they
sent me the script I thought here is a
woman with a lot more to her than I
remember from the tablet
what would make a 36 year old woman have
an affair with a seventh grader people
they like see me as a victim
I wanted it
I already have an idea of what it must
have felt like or sneaking around with
you
[Music]
someone who you think is a bad person
it's the more gray areas that are
interesting she's getting on my last
nerve she's just everywhere I look
why can't we talk about it if it really
is in love as we say we are
insecure people are very dangerous
aren't they
are
crazy